a beautiful blast from the past and an
extremely rare one at that
Gustav Bauer is driving a piece of
automotive history the Porsche name is
displayed proudly at the back but this
car was built and tuned Switzerland not
in Porsches hometown have stood God
the Google diet Christoph explains that
when the auto industry was in its
infancy cars were made by hand the big
manufacturers only provided the chassis
the engine and the fittings customers
had to order the body individually from
a coach maker by the 1950s this practice
was rare but the boiler firm from toon
Switzerland continued to do excellent
body work one example is this wonderful
coupe a a 1957 Volkswagen Porsche boiler
six nine six one four the ticket am
stand Fritz boiler had already
established contacts at Porsche back in
1948 six of the very first Porsches 356s
had bodies made by the boiler brothers
including the oldest series production
Porsche is still in existence car number
double O 3 but the coach makers had
aspirations of their own an elegant
coupe a with four seats and superior
engineering that drives like a sports
car
impossible no said pounced and fits boy
play they acquired the chassis of a VW
Bug began to hammer out a suitable body
and this was the fruit of their labor
the Porsche boiler
696 a real eye-catcher
the body of the boiler Porsche 696 was
made entirely of aluminum while this
material was difficult to work with the
boilers had used it before in specially
commissioned jobs from which rebrand
such as Bristol Lancia Packard and
Sampson Christophe explains that the
boiler brothers founded their own coach
building business just after World War
Two in the little Swiss town of tune at
first they specialized in repairing
vehicles damaged in accidents but they
were soon attracting well-known
customers including ferry Porsche and
give us a portion so it wasn't hard for
the boilers to get this particular
four-door coupe a fitted with an engine
that normally powered Porsches sports
cars the other boy learned 696 is used a
reliable and cheaper mass production
engine provided by Volkswagen
most boiler coupe A's were powered by
the VW Beetle inch it explains
christophe with a Judson compressor
providing extra performance but that
wasn't enough for this cars first owner
hear that sound
I can alright that's Porsche is
engineering in the back Christoph says
the four-cylinder boxer engine generated
seventy-five horsepower and pushed the
coupe aid to a top speed of 165
kilometers an hour just the thing for
those looking to live life in the fast
lane in the late 50s
though it's a product of the 1950s the
boilers styling is coolly understated
but then the Swiss do like to remain
neutral
the only extravagant feature is the mock
radiator grille because in fact this
cars engine is in the rear
the interiors monochrome color scheme
looks smart with a radio from blob
punked and high quality leather
upholstery the boiler Porsche was both
luxurious and suitable for everyday use
the trunk at the front can hold quite a
bit more than just a golf bag it's not
and here at the back is the legendary
Porsche boxer engine from the 356 a its
twin Zenith carburetors allow it to
generate 75 horsepower this engine alone
cost 3600 Swiss francs more than the
standard VW one but Christophe says it's
worth every cent team
flipping between the classy old resort
towns of the island of rügen the boiler
Portia's really in its element because
in its day only the rich could afford to
own one Christophe says in 1957 this
Kupe sold for almost 20,000 Swiss francs
as much as four standard VW beetles but
exclusivity has its price and the Swiss
could afford the better things in life
still Switzerland is a small country so
just four of these Coupe A's were ever
sold and spoiler kept the fifth one for
himself and drove it until the 1990s
just five of these upscale cars were
ever built using engineering borrowed
from Porsche and Volkswagen and a
hand-hammered body from a small Swiss
coach maker so can the boiler Coupe a
really qualify as a milestone in
automotive history the boiler brothers
were the first in Europe to make a four
seater sports coupe a with outstanding
driver characteristics it would be many
years until cars like the VW Scirocco
Ford Capri and Opel Manta introduced the
idea to the masses so for that reason
Christoph feels the Volkswagen Porsche
boiler is definitely an automotive
milestone and the boiler Coupe a is also
one of the most beautiful cars ever
built what a shame that the tradition of
making car bodies by hand is slowly
dying out
you